do you think we're going to see a debate
between the two of them
because i know biden agreed to three of
them do you think we're actually going
to see a debate
i i'm shocked that the democrats have
kept
biden in the race i mean it's
unbelievable
you you have to be consumed
with a rabid hatred of trump
to even consider that biden
is a candidate even before he got
dementia
i mean i don't know that he can tie his
own shoelaces these days but even before
he got dementia
he's a nasty piece of work i don't know
how he gets the reputation of being
uncle joe or some good guy
you know he's a bully
he he he will say anything he's a
political [ __ ]
um and he's a he's got a mafiosi
mentality or you look at the way he
threatened the
prime minister of the u of ukraine you
know i'm going to get on a plane if
if you haven't fired this prosecutor
who's going after my corrupt son
uh i'm going to take a billion dollars
uh
you know out of your pocket that the
congress has already voted for you
and then the same son of a [ __ ] biden
he attacks trump who didn't give a quick
quote to the ukrainians
and has perfectly comfortable with you
know trying to overthrow him
i can't say bad enough things about joe
i've never liked joe biden
i can't say bad enough things about him
he's made every immediate member of his
family his wife his sister
when we can't distinguish between his
brother
his son they're all millionaires and
multi-millionaires off the government
tit
arranged by joe biden
what what can you say about this guy
that's positive unless you're lying
so now you believe it he's supporting
you know bernie sanders program bernie
sanders a lifelong
communist they're probably never a
member of the party
but he's defended every communist
dictator and every communist atrocity
um you know for 60 years
learned nothing and he's an angry nasty
piece of work
he ate he hates billionaires he doesn't
hate millionaires because he is one
anyway so do you think the debate's
going to happen between the two of them
i can't answer that i i i sure
yes it looks like the democrats are
committed
to running this you know it's like
weekend at bernie's that film with a
real little corpse around